what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to talk to you guys
about how i got banned from tick tock
temporarily
um for the next couple of weeks and it
actually has something to do with fresh
and fit
so um i'm gonna tell you this story but
before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification
bow um that way you're gonna be notified
of my daily videos as you guys know
20 000 subscribers big goal for the
channel and i need each and every one of
you to help me
get there okay so where do i start
i wanted to go on the fresh and fit
podcast i felt like that would be a fire
collab and if i could get on that show
um that you know that would just be
really great for my channel so
i dm'd fresh and fit and um
myron um actually dm me and said if you
can get a tick tock account to 100 000
followers
you can come on the
[Music]
fresh and fit podcast like we usually
charge otherwise like it'll be free for
you
i say cool that that sounds good to me
i'm pretty good with tick tock
i think that you know
like if if it was something that would
take a lot of work um
it would be one thing but i just didn't
feel like it would be super hard to get
an account
um with that much viral account content
to 100 000 subscribers like i just i
felt like i could do it i really wanted
to go on the show
um so i made a backup account like not
my main tick tock
but a backup tick tock dedicated just to
posting fashion fit and i
posted literally one
um video like it was like one of their
most viral clips from their freshman fit
clips account and i picked one that i
did not feel like was super
out there like i felt like it was one of
their more pg clips
and my ass got banned within two days
which is nuts to me because the club was
just saying that a lot of women might
end up alone according to this guy's
like projections but
you know that's not set in stone you
know the future is in
our hands i didn't think that was crazy
controversial
and literally and not only so on tick
tock and this is what people don't know
when you get like temporarily banned um
they will ban all the accounts on your
device so only
my backup count account is the one
that's banned but i actually can't log
in
on any of the five accounts that i run
and it kind of sucks because i have a
rejection therapy series
that i'm trying to do and i literally
can't post it on my tick tock
so i'm on daylight 30 and i think my
fans i usually post every day so i think
my fans are gonna think i'm dead
um but yeah that's how i got banned from
take talk but it's kind of messed up
because
i really don't think like fresh and fit
doesn't have
content that i 100 agree with but i
cannot believe that they're being
censored to the point
that their accounts get banned within
two days
like that's nuts so let me know in the
comments if any of you guys have had
issues with censorship on tiktok
or any other platforms like what
platforms do you think would be the best
and the worst